bella tutti ragazzi e questo lo vide io
sono per i gelesi sono i players one con
cacao sono un cactus è la migliore
dietro gli abbia mai sentito la mia vita
possiamo vincere ragazzi non so quante
partite avete mai vinto no però legata
posta secondo me no vi giuro non ho
chiamato volevi dire subito all'inter
video che abbiamo mai vinto
è vero volevo solo sull colpa ma ora
solo un video quindi allora va bene
allora vi dico un paio di tattiche che
possono sempre che io ho giocato fino a
diventare stupido quindi e sorelle ho
dimenticato la matematica però adesso so
giocare a win for guys quindi prima roba
il primo è il primo livello è proprio
random nel senso che è proprio tutta na
caciara quindi non c'è niente di tattica
baie vivi primo lo passate spero di nasi
dai starfish ma non è vero e lo è per
migliorare la effe è un chilometro e
merci a posto per andata giù bravi di
second life e regia poi ancora fare ci
sono ancora persone davanti ma ce la fai
queste cadono fidati vai vai vai su sia
a sinistra fidati non a destra sinistra
ci siete mai detto mi ha ucciso prima mi
appunti bloccato di proposito non mi
ricordo che cactus sei tu che numero 9
roma in questa arrivo quasi sempre primo
forse arrivato terzo mista un secondo
no secondo serie di step josè arrivato
nella lista
[Applauso]
questo qua è semplice ma alla fine ne
l'ultima rampa non andate in mezzo
perché non serve
non puoi non vuoi farmi anno centro non
centro brava che sono tipi la lappata
fortissimo inutile arriva questo è molto
più facile dell'altro che abbiamo fatto
davvero come livello 1 sì a me sopreso
tutti uguali sono ultimo ragazzi appena
l'ho detto mi ha afferrato e certo
perfetto non devi dire niente ovviamente
devia in quel santa sul giallo e poi
senza arrampicarti stato sociale
psicologico tornato hanno fatto un
lavoro ma ci siete si mesi sono oltre la
dopo la prima palla lanciati perchè
serve sempre lanciarsi mi manca poco
raga quanto vi manca messaggio c6
apposta per lei
ecco ti vedo 6 7 9 14
ti vedo ti vedo devi stare dritta stefer
no dritta dritta dritta dritta linea qui
dai dopo che porta questo dai tanti
adesso adesso di nuovo
brava no dai dritta ok ora aspetta che
gli arriva adesso risalta adesso risalta
bravo vai e tu fatico infatti ducati
bravissima cori oggi non c'è gente
eliminata non è possibile ma dai
sono migliorato la novità non è male
almeno ma che strano dove che sei
stefano livello per il tuo maledetto
numero 139
1329 ok sono tutti i cactus qua non va
bene allora tu non hai la cosa va i cori
attacca ma facciamo anche passare
volendo sai
sì sì sì sì questo qua me l'ha rubata
subito senza lui non gliene fregava
niente nel cose che girano 41 secondi
oggi manca poco lontano
allora in samarate conta sì ok io ce
l'ho ok vado tasto rosso quindi si
attaccano loro perché questo ce l'ha con
me che celano sto fermo
c'era un rosso fermo lì che cosa vuoi da
me siamo a 7 watt e non usciamo noi non
usciamo
ho fatto perfetto perfetto allora questa
qua semplicemente lo slime inizia a
salire pian piano e tu devi arrivare
alla fine la cosa importante è che lì
non è e non deve arrivare primo non ci
sono eliminati
se non quelli che cadono nello slang
quindi sereni quando lei non c'è uno che
rimane tagliato fuori
se non dallo slang non toccatelo dai
quindi non devi essere comunque
abbastanza lento devi essere veloce ma
non devi gareggiare con gli altri poi
immagine di non ci sia nessuno solo
questo non toccare lo slime by lento
tranquillo ma ti saltano sul caso giallo
vedi che non sono soltanto non serve a
niente
tutti che saltano addosso la gente e tra
la gente traiana mi spingono molto
carina io ero già co ed eliminato
ragazzi mi hanno spinto a tema mi hanno
spinto gli altri io sono veramente
triste
allora questo è quello che voglio di più
spesso web perché ci sono seagate che
continuano andare di sopra ma io non
azzecco mai il timing ma è solo
questioni timing sto livello solo timing
ma io non l'ho azzecco mai perché faccio
schifo parti l appuntamento di un sempre
ritardo siete la ragazza era solo la
figlia sono vicini bravi si parla solita
alla fine c'è un salto occhio andare
dove c'è già la barriera che dopo almeno
crescita su madonna ha fatto un salto in
avanti dove sei feriti saltare troppo ha
detto dove sei e così no vai e salta
saltos prima si schiantino questi non ce
l'hai fatta
ne vado ma è incredibile e tp lo questa
non era facile il finale è più semplice
non sono mica tutto sullo schianto
finale però a ma perché non me la prende
la facciamo ce la facciamo
premiare i rondoni non so come te lo
giuro io ogni volta che tento di
prendere una cosa devo essere di
appiccicato gli atem e la strappano da
un chilometro
davvero non so veramente non ho paura
amici mi è arrivato un saab mi sono
cagato nelle mutande a posto va bene
stai tranquillo vai tra basta che non ci
cadi non ti far spingere non ti fa
specie se ai bordi piuttosto periferiche
salvo sly non tifa spingere giulia e
maledetto sto gioco attenzione alle
palle
chi è che michele fermo ok ha posto oggi
mai se l'è bravo bravo va bene adesso
stiamo di brega no non fatti beccare non
lo so anch'io sono caduto con ricarico a
ricaricare ok ok ok tuffati bravo non
c'è bisogno di lasciare basta che non
cadi basta che non cade e non tifa
spingere nemmeno siete tutti i cactus ma
è normale ma tutti di cactus ma perché
si vede che all'andata ha voglia di
famiglia
ok musik ha avuto bravura o che questo è
semplicissima e questo semplicissimo mai
solo dritto
seguimi se è bravo sì mi piace ok
fermati fermati fermati qua bravo ancora
uno non cadere bravo così funziona vai
ancora va ancora occhio anche poi
maledetta filati sembra facile ma la
frase terribile e terribile l'ultimo
manca l'ultimo io ci sono e ci sono 26
st
ma che cosa vuoi tu mollami maledetto
come bravo di affermato quello
lo stiamo vedendo
ma perché c'è la gente infame ci sono
quegli infami che fanno sta roba
ma poi non sai quanta gente ho visto che
fa l'infame poi cadde perché la villa lo
colpisce marotta guarda questi che sono
tutto ma sai questi quel carne come li
colpisce male finale ma come finale di
sciacca senette
no ragazzi non ho mai fatto un finale
con così tanta gente e non si può fare
no raga finale qua no non è possibile ma
come fai a fare una finale 17
ma partiamo che la dld a voler avere più
esatto scusa ma siamo anche dietro anche
una fila dietro non vale
ma come finali 17 ma come sono che ha
due perché io personaggi e stupido è
inceppato l'ho solo ma dai ma cosa
inciampi io sono partito una fila dietro
la scusa minuto il criterio quasi
aicardi una volta hai perso perché gli
altri si stesse o di ho visto un casinò
infatti stati tranciati tutti solo una
volta avanti
dovendo è caduto ci sono io non ci credo
no no no niente per niente per niente se
non inciampa o se non inciampava
all'inizio di un personaggio da solo è
inciampato da solo non ha fatto niente è
sceso un gradino e sugli champs atto gli
altri hanno cedono sono inciampati se
non fosse inciampato li avrei vinto
perché sollevata o niente che si fa
niente è stato comunque bello che nel
prossimo programma vincere
pronto anche tevere ok promesso
iscrivetevi ciao ciao mipiace che è
sempre utile come sempre ci vediamo
quanto sei bella ragazza
[Musica]